what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are here for cobra kai
cf52 uh you're gonna watch this right
now ladies and gentlemen uh we're joined
with john how are you i am fantastic
andy gordon how are you i'm doing well
my friend thank you these shirts are
comfortable andrew got them for us i'll
mention in every video yeah subscribe
and click that notification bell get
notified when our reaction for the next
episode of cobra kai is up leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated super
duper helps us out bull length reaction
watch as long as we sync up with your
own copy of cobra kai over for super
sexy rejects at our patreon page where
we cover several shows the same tier
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included exclusively last of the team at
prepper thank you for listening down
these highlights if you're already
binging with us you probably skipped all
that intro so let's watch this show
[Music]
ah
holy crap i didn't think we'd be getting
this here
what's your
[Music]
my
i love that we're getting all this
backstory chosen has become one of my
favorite characters
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey
hey
[Music]
you're gonna hit your own car man
little guy is a real harmful hectic did
you ever think of heaven anymore
he's not mine he's from her previous
marriage never had any kid of my own
perfect even got married
we started talking about having kids
and then i did some terrible things
you can leave mexico without a few
stories right
please
i owe you let me show you a good time
this looks like the mexican version of
the larusso house i was just thinking
that actually
i don't just fight for a trophy i want
to be strong to defend what's mine what
about you
might be a sensei oh no
that's it
that is everything
i thought i had lost my honor um cricket
do reference
no one can take honor from you
only you can take honor from yourself
how's it going here i like that
sentimentality where are you from
exactly sensei
kyoto i've always loved the fushimi
inari shrine uh too many tourists
nanzanji temple
much better for your next visit
let's have a japan off
guy at the impound lot said we need 4
000 pesos it's like a million dollars
[Laughter]
it's a red sabina
i think i'll burn a hole right through
you oh this camera this camera this
camera this is our shot to get back on
track
i'll do it
no rob i got us into this like you said
this is our best shot
[Music]
and i know i can win
it's like karate kid part two with
daniel with the ice
i was thinking the deer hunter
uno moss
[Music]
give me the hottest pepper you got
he is nothing like what you said he was
you you were wrong about me he's smart
he's generous he's respected he uh oh
he's like a mob boss
he's about to learn the truth
[Laughter]
even the jar is hot
[Music]
use that kata to eat the pepper
[Music]
did he palm it
yeah
yeah buddy disrespectful ruined all that
money disgusting way to win nichols
what's on your mind
excited to take things to the next level
what's the point
you'll just pay to make me champion
again
wow
it was an insurance policy you still won
the fight
did i of course you did
you're the champion
i know it but russo knows it the whole
valley knows it
if you don't believe it then you're the
only person who doesn't oh my god such a
manipulator
if you choose to leave
i won't hold it against you
but if you come back tomorrow
i will make you the future of this dojo
you snake
he's such a master manipulator i love it
[Laughter]
what were you chewing on then
nice
that was very clever this is acceptable
cheating
i made a lot of money back in the day
but not in the restaurant business the
kind of business where you make a lot of
friends in high places
enemies too
but i put the password
[Applause]
step back from that ledge my friend
this plan has an expiration date
silver's too smart
eventually he'll figure us out
and when he does
be ready to fight
yamazaki such a
faster rhythm to this season
i lost a fight
a fight i should have won
rivalries die slow deaths i have a rival
in this dojo business in fact scotland
russo
there's some michael keating quality
about it hector the salazar
passover
[Laughter]
look at the back of the shirts
still they say fbi in the front
[Laughter]
who were you on the phone with earlier
just my mom she's checking up on her not
all right right right right now are you
with the fats no no no absolutely not
hey
give me your phone
i got nothing i'm going to mail me oh
make me ask again holy [ __ ] she just
turned really scary
i know he's good
he's gonna see a picture of carmen isn't
he i'm gonna look through your entire
phone
[Applause]
sorry
people are not always what they seem
you can never be too short
take it from me
such an ironic line
[Applause]
mexico has an experienced eagle thing
johnny
[Music]
[Laughter]
elbow to the nose
[Music]
i'm with the female body inspector i
figured you'd appreciate that very much
this one
dude
terry's so good he's so suspicious of
him
he'll get that rich without being
suspicious a toast then
two
riding the wrongs of the past
and coming back on top
katie
oh man that's scary
all that money
[Laughter]
i'm gonna lay low a few days
maybe a week or two
grandma yeah
and then louise
totally fine
she's only after my money in the first
place
that's a big shot this dude is drinking
all the time
that woman i told you about she couldn't
stun me doing my business and her mother
even worse
[Music]
and you know what i regret
nothing
wow
i should probably get going actually
you should at least tell
them what for they get so complicated
i would never make a phone call in this
guy's eye line i know
or talk to anybody hey mom
oh
[Music]
you were right
please tell me you're okay mickey
miguel
his real father showed up
give robbie a hug too
what an interesting note and that's you
know where's everyone else
no class today
there's some business i need to take
care of
oh
what a shot arrangement
am i hurting on the contrary
right on time
falling
i take out all the senseis
yeah he knows the truth
every time
i raise a class with one of my old
friends from kyoto we toast come by
with my new friend
kyoto yeah race is a glass some glorious
bastard [ __ ]
only say
in okinawa yeah
[Music]
you bastard anyone who takes this man
down
gets the job
and i will pay triple what i promised
if chosen wins does he get the job yeah
yeah
it's the sorry six times are it man soon
oh damn you have to mess these boys up
the sigh
nice
[Music]
that guy knew
texting me
just not doing anything
daddy
[Music]
oh jesus
yeah
and i take the job
homeboy likes a challenge
hey so hard right now
he's going to call him mike barnes
let's get him back
oh man
buddy buddy all right john
andrew went first last time take it away
we're gonna watch it
in just a minute so john go i am loving
the season so far i i you commented that
it is moving kind of at a breakneck
speed i was a little taken aback that we
may be wrapping up the mexico story at
least in mexico for right now but i i i
loved the whole journey for miguel
uh i thought the stuff with robbie and
johnny was really fun and everything
with chosen and terry i thought was
really nicely rendered because it's
tense and it's like a chess game back
and forth and they constantly have you
wondering okay how much does this dude
know when is the shoe gonna drop because
everything that chosen and danny are
doing right now is is
assured but a little too confident so
you know there's a shoe ready to drop
and i thought the way they they
orchestrated that mind game was really
nice like you said in glorious bastards
hell yeah yeah i agree with everything
you said i think uh one thing that i
really enjoyed in this episode before i
get to the easter eggs uh was tori and
chosen
they have very interesting past um and
the way they relate to each other was
really interesting about you know
cowardness and cheating and finding the
easy way and i really appreciated those
moments together and i'm really looking
forward i mean obviously we know
chosen's not going to be working with
cobra guys so you know they're not going
to be having too many more scenes of
training together but just again those
scenes we did get i really appreciate it
and they held a lot of weight for me uh
which i wasn't expecting but uh i was
kind of
kind of taken aback too like you said uh
with the the breakneck speed of this
episode i was kind of uh you know really
curious that they went the decision to
have terry figure out that chosen so
quickly uh was working with daniel that
was an interesting decision i'm curious
to see how it pays off through the rest
of the season
but uh i love those two
together because they have such a
complicated history with at least with
daniel larussa so seeing those two
interacting with each other and just
laying it out and again just the chess
game that they were playing it just it
made for such good storytelling and such
good interactions with each other i
really love those moments and robbie and
johnny they're really good together as
well i love that storyline and then
as we pointed out in episode one we knew
that the there were some ulterior uh you
know i don't know if we would say uh
motives but at least from a character
perspective we knew that the dad wasn't
miguel's biological father was not who
he seemed to be and we knew that was
going to happen so
that dude that actors really got ranged
because he seems like such a sweet
mundane nice gentleman in the first
episode and then in like a really quick
second he turned into a really scary guy
there when he's like let me see your
phone and all that so actor's really
good uh but a couple quick uh easter
eggs and references because i know you
guys are all dying for them uh the ones
that i the ones that i noticed uh when
they're doing the betting and uh johnny
betts all in on uh
robbie uh that was very similar to
karate kid part two and
uh daniel has to do the ice uh thing uh
again sato betsan chose or bets against
daniel and mr miyagi bets on daniel very
similar to that i believe when uh
uh chosen as being called a coward by
sato i believe he calls mr miyagi a
coward in part two if i'm wrong please
let me know in the comments section and
you should know i should know i know my
bad guys i believe so and then uh where
he says he had uh you know he's talking
about with tori with no honor and all
that that's obviously how we felt at the
end of karate kid part two which we saw
in the references i could be totally off
on this one but when johnny is fighting
the mma guy and then throws the pepper
or puts the pepper in his eyes to help
him defeat him it really felt similar to
me at least to the ending of three
ninjas that was made in 1992 uh where
the grandpa is about to lose to the bad
guy snyder in the film and he puts jelly
beans in his mouth and that helps him
defeat him in the end so uh very similar
to that i don't know i'm throwing
spitballing i mean it's kind of just the
motif yeah there you go and then one
other thing i did for him i did forget
to mention in the first episode but we
saw a little bit of again miguel's
little well i guess that wasn't his
biological brother but uh the the little
boy that uh miguel's biological father
the son of yes exactly uh he's playing
he's kicking with the soccer ball very
similar to uh karate kid part one where
daniel is kicking the soccer ball on his
knee and showing ali how to do it yeah
dude
it's all connected it's all connected
all definitely easter eggs
is miguel's alley
yes
yeah uh i think what they're doing so i
mean when i said that the speed that
it's moving at i actually like the speed
because there's such a
there's such a great rhythm to it that
keeps sort of this uh suspense alive
throughout like you know you're you're
on a train going somewhere
and again because i've been viewing this
through the lens of a season four part
two it's not feeling rushed to me i'm
like no this is good we're just getting
we're just getting this train going
let's go let's go you know it's like
leading somewhere because yeah they're
doing a lot of that sort of editing
choices of having characters talk and
then overlapping into a scene that's
happening later on so like a present so
you have one part where daniel and
chosen are talking now it's already
moving on to the next scene and their
dialogue from that scene is overlapping
so we can keep the flow going and so i
like i like the speed of it actually i
really did enjoy it i think the stuff
with miguel and his dad was pretty
powerful i think that actor whoever
plays the dad like you were talking
about was excellent like the he because
he seems like he does have just so much
turmoil from his past like that whole
speech when he's lamenting about having
no regrets you can tell he's like
bullshitting himself that there is just
so much pain and sorrow in this guy but
he chooses a very specific path to go
down like he has chosen to leave behind
the loved ones so there is no point in
miguel trying to confide to this guy
like hey i actually am your son
there is no true purpose to it i like
how this show carries on those themes of
familial bonds and understanding the
difference between blood connection and
then who we choose to define as our
family as well like it was so tender i
forgot all about johnny
and robbie um but when they did show up
i was so in the in the moment of what
was happening and i i thought i've never
learned how to say his name properly uh
does anyone know how to say his name
properly the actor plays miguel
oh i could attempt to spell it better
than i know how to say it show low there
you go
i think miguel i think his performance
is just excellent like i i love what
he's doing here so much more than what i
i want to say he's been slighted in the
last couple of seasons he's always been
great but like i remember the first
season he was such like
one of the focuses
yeah he was such a central figure and
then it's kind of bringing it back to
that
and i think he's excellent and he and
this is the kind of shoe really yeah
would watch his blue beetle movie like
look how good of an actor this guy is
he's amazing
and of course like the fight scenes with
johnny and robbie kind of having a buddy
comedy situation of father and son and
getting into these these adventures with
each other and they're like beating up
people in mexico
it's funny [ __ ] it's funny [ __ ]
and yeah the stuff the scenes were
chosen and terry uh sizing each other up
and trying to figure each other out like
you just know i've never i've never
noticed but there's like a michael
keating quality to tear to the actor who
who's taylor silver thomas ian griffith
one day you'll remember that there's a
very very michael keating quality to the
way the man talks at times they got the
same mouth they do there's a similar
mouth and delivery at times and there's
like there's there is that uh
does that be devious devious quality
about the way they talk and i love it
basically what greg's saying if they
ever reboot beetlejuice this is their
guy this is their guy right here don't
use the actual michael keaton
use thomas ian griffin griffith yeah
whatever
thomasi and griffith thomas ian church
uh yeah used thomas ian griffith for it
so yeah i mean there's still because
there's so many story lines right now
that they do have to kind of balance it
out with what you can focus on like we
didn't really get much daniel this time
around
um no samantha we haven't really checked
in with many of the students from miyagi
though no they were kind of just like
background players in the last episode
and they're nowhere here they just
showed up
yeah they're barely
there's so much that they have to flesh
out and it's it's keeping it very
right now it's just like really just so
focused on the main characters
and i'm like i'm liking what they're
doing so far and uh it does feel
different like it's i like that ad i
just love that tone that this show has
that
that suspenseful cheese is the best way
i can describe it like it's always like
a little cheesy but still like just
gripping where i'm not laughing at the
show for what it's doing
it's just the right pitch where it's
having fun
but it's also like intense and cares a
lot about its characters it's really
great i really love this show yeah and
they find ways of mixing and fight like
i feel like in season two or three maybe
there was like a peak of like man there
are just fights all the time this is
getting like a little too high
concept almost for the world that it's
in and i feel like they've balanced the
the appropriate amount of cheese to
motivate the fights where it's like
they're fun and bouncy but they're also
kind of cool you know
well it's all about balance yeah that's
right
i mean the the fights are perfect for
the cobra kai karate kid world yeah yeah
like there is a lot of like attack one
at a time people waiting for a hit
to happen someone back there not doing
anything you know there's actually
there's a little fight
it's the way it but it works for the
world yeah it is you know if i was
watching like a john wick movie i would
be like what's going on here if you're
watching donnie yen you'd be like what's
that yeah but for the karate kid world
i'm like nah it's perfect this is this
this is the fighting style of the 80s
right now i want to add one last thing
that scene we got with miguel where he's
crying on the phone to his mother and
then johnny shows up it really felt like
a very nice payoff to that very
emotionally weighted scene that we got
uh towards the end of season four after
the prom where miguel came to johnny's
uh how our apartment and johnny
and he called him robbie it was it just
felt like a nice payoff to that scene
but in a better way for miguel yeah it's
true it's very true
i think this time they're finally gonna
get along they're probably gonna have to
like fight it out or something they'll
fight and then they'll become brothers
yeah i think this is the because last
time last season was about johnny and
daniel coming together and now it's i
think it's going to be about robbie and
miguel coming together and then sam and
tory
double dating oh what if it ends on a
double date
oh man that would be nice that'd be
really lovely
interesting but lovely more to come more
to come guys
uh what'd you guys think of this episode
leave your thoughts down below keep a
lookout for episode three we're gonna
watch in just a couple minutes so
subscribe click that bell leave a like
before we go to this with the patreon
brendan benzie
brendan
we're gonna look at what your name means
in urban dictionary today drum roll
please because you know what looking up
the actual name meanings what's the
point
here we go brandon is the friend you
want to keep because he will put others
before himself
he cares about everyone especially to
the people he knows best it's true we
have a friend named brandon and uh he is
like that so i would just assume so
you're like that you're the exact same
way
my fiance dater to brandon
i hate that guy brandon can make girls
laugh and make them feel like the only
girl in the world good for you man you
know our the brandon we know can do that
too
and uh so did
fiance's ex
when he makes jokes it's usually to make
people feel happy he made my fiance very
very happy sounds like he was a great
guy everything i've heard when he does
things with but that means you do that
when he does things with his friends it
usually ends with trouble oh brandon
you're crazy guy crazy crazy guy brandon
role so it was my fiancee zacks he was
just always uh he's always getting into
trouble belongs in prison brandon is the
person to keep secrets because he wants
to make sure they can let out anything
that they wanted to say
it's good that we can trust you and i
have told my fiancee zach so many of my
darkest secrets
i went there to hit him and then it did
not it went completely opposite i was
opening my soul he made you feel like
the only girl in the world brandon
sometimes can be a dick
but deep inside he is a loving person he
will get a fight with someone if he has
to it's good you can protect us at our
patreon page you can protect us
and he um
of course you know my fiance sex he uh
he he's he's he's he's so full of dick
he fights a lot of you uh brandon
honestly is someone you need in your
life because he'll do whatever he has to
do to make you feel happy he would make
a wonderful boyfriend because he will
care about you and protect you with his
life
dude like a good safety jacket i'm
leaving my fiancee so she can get back
with brandon
it's for the best
friend thank you so much for being here
buddy
and it looks usually around a dictionary
means something mean or perverted you've
got a sweet treat
you've got a great urban dictionary
thanks for being part of our patreon
page buddy
[Music]
you